Pakistani investigators have released
CCTV video purportedly showing the
moment a suicide bomber managed to
infiltrate what is supposed to be a
secure area dressed in a police uniform
and riding a motorbike he was simply
waved through without any checks the
question of security Labs was there
I admit that yes there was a security
Labs just because
the suicide bomber was dressed in a
police uniform the entire command of the
police lines Gates is not under one
Authority because inside there are seven
different smaller units or organizations
and each one has their own command
structure and therefore the confusion
the chaos caused this
detectable yet undetected entry into the
police lines and undetected the suicide
bomber continued to his Target
this CCTV footage shows him leaving his
motorbike by the roadside he's then
called back by a police officer
is his bike away pretending it had
broken down this is the last checkpoint
the suicide bomber would have gone
through before making his way to the
mosque investigators say the police vest
who is wearing was filled with 10 to 12
kilograms of explosives they also say it
appears the attacker didn't know where
the mosque was and had to ask for
directions
further footage released by police shows
the man walking towards the mosque where
he would go on to inflict the single
largest loss of life the police here
have ever suffered and as they come to
terms with their loss questions about
what else can be done to protect
security Personnel still remain
there's no modern technology to protect
police facilities having facial
recognition or fingerprints or biometric
entry etc etc on the level of technology
which is internationally accepted as a
standard feature
the resources that are required probably
those are either not available or we are
not having those funerals are still
taking place police Chiefs are trying to
keep the morale High among the 130 000
strong force in the province
but there's concern there could be more
attacks
I said Big Al Jazeera the shower